as so often happens in Hollywood people
are with films and stories for a very
long time and this is no exception
so where were you in 2005 and what were
you doing when you read CPS obituary and
started on this 14-year journey
yeah I was in my office at our bungalow
at Universal Studios I was producing for
a writer director named Gary Ross and
there was on the milestones page in Time
magazine CP Ellis had died clan member
who became union activist I kind of
blinked and I said well how did that
happen so I found the book and read
about it found out about it out water
and saw a documentary which you saw some
of the clips from and that's when it
really crystallized for me seeing them
talk about each other and such fond
terms you know all those years later I
said okay well this this is this is
gonna be a story and you had a
relationship with Anne you've got to
meet her and yeah so I had originally
had the rights for the book in 2009 as a
producer didn't really know what to do
with it let it lapse and then after I
went produced another movie in 2013 I
decided I that's what I want to write in
direct so the book was still available
which was fortunate and I got on a plane
and made a beeline for Durham and called
Anne and went to where she was at a
nursing home she'd hurt her leg so we
sat down and had lunch which I didn't
know they call lunch dinner there too
so I you know I was like wait aren't we
supposed to meet at 1:00 yeah so but she
was great and we just but we had a
relationship for three years before she
passed and Bill Riddick still alive he's
been with us on the press tour he's been
great so yeah it was just everybody
antastic ray yeah did you did you have
to sell an on the idea was she open to
it I think at first the the first phone
call I made to her before I saw the next
day she said call my lawyer and his
number is and that's the first thing so
it wasn't until we met and we talked and
she right away we clicked and but that's
like a Charette you know she didn't know
me I'm sure she's been approached before
yeah so there was a little guardedness I
think
about five minutes and then fast friends
that's I've saved all my voicemails from
her and we've all heard them it's really
emotional so yeah
well Matt and Dominique what was it like
to produce a film with somebody who's
been a producer for 20 years that
question is pressed or interesting
question you know it actually makes the
producers job easier I have to say I you
know this film there are a lot of
challenges there are plenty of obstacles
to overcome but when you're working with
someone who gets it and can even be
helpful and has strengths and areas
where you're weak and and you know it
actually made it more fun you know to
not have to explain every wasn't a
typical first-timer put it that way yeah
that's definitely true but he definitely
had a lot of spirited discussions
because anything he would share with us
well I mean to you know Robin came from
producing Hunger Games just guess what
that budget was this budget was not that
little spear so in 29 days versus what
90 days so with I think it was a little
bit of an adjustment but how many pages
a day do i yeah yeah and I have to do a
company move three out of every five
days so it was a little bit of an
adjustment but I you know I'm very I
think we are very happy with with the
results yeah we have good stories and
memories right now let's talk about the
cast and what kind of conversations you
and Robin had obviously taraji and Sam
but then you know did you do local
casting and then I'd like to talk about
Sid Babu am I saying that right
yeah and what made what made a Brit the
right choice to play Riddick first I'll
say that Robin and I go way back to the
very beginning of both of our careers so
we've so as soon as he called to say he
was going to direct something I'm pretty
sure I didn't even read it and I said
sure and and then when when it all
really came to
with the money and the money was and
Robin knew this was going to be you know
limiting I you know I've done so much
work in the southeast because there's so
much film and television production and
in Georgia but really in the entire
southeast and so I said one way we can
save you some money is I'll do the whole
top to bottom I mean I actually know
that southeastern talent pool really
well so we and really the the main thing
really is I mean I can do it but Robin
really I couldn't do it without Robin
being willing to work quickly and
decisively so we it was a very tidy
process for us to sort of nail down that
entire cast I remember
the costume designer called us to say
that in their entire career they had
never had every single actor closed deal
memo three or so weeks before shooting
they were in shock so there's so many
good actors there that people who didn't
maybe get the part that they auditioned
for we said okay we liked that person so
much let's have them play this part this
part so we filled in all the the roles
like that and so so Babu was the last
piece of the puzzle because this is a
longer story but his Los Angeles manager
introduced me to him via his press kit
because he had just been nominated for a
BAFTA Award and he was he had that such
a warm smiley face and those eyes and I
just thought I really thought Bill
Riddick should seem you know very warm
you know and so the challenge for Babu
was to prove to everybody that he could
convincingly portray an American because
he had never been asked to do that so he
he worked on his accent we Skyped a few
times and and then he was the answer and
he and he Denis Woods I mean he came
days before shooting he this was three
weeks before nice woods let's yes what's
up but yeah three weeks before he had
never been in the country and remember
this is the spring of 2017 there's all
new visa
issues then yeah and we had to route him
through Toronto and I think he got down
a day or two before he started shooting
we almost didn't get him there yeah and
I thought he was great did he have a
dialect coach Denis was ya gonna keep
repeating yeah he he hopscotched
I mean he piggybacked with Suraj's
dialect coach who was already there and
she's amazing
I know it's always a challenge to sort
of articulate put into words the
creative process but let's talk about
your crazy
well you know words are it's interesting
that it's a words there are towards that
Robin told me very early on it was
common humanity and we talked I think we
even titled one of the scenes and one of
the cues dad and I that was the thing
that really was from the very beginning
how to capture the music of that was
common to all of these people without
necessarily just obviously the source is
much more local and much more of the
time but the score had to capture more
of their souls really and and the idea
of common humanity kept always running
through my mind of how do these
characters from such a so far away could
could come together with music with our
resorting to stereotypes the the movies
I mean extremely dark at times and but
the music always kind of was threading
this place of letting the audience make
up their own mind especially with CPS
you know and and allowing Sam I mean
it's his what can you say about the
performance I mean it's just incredible
and he really leads her there without
you realizing you were there bye-bye the
final speech and it was it was always
about not pushing too far and not not
being just a bit short of the
condescending type of score which is
something that both me and Robin agreed
that we did not want you know we didn't
want to take the audience by the hand we
wanted this story to be told and the
music supported and and some wise I
think well I always had this sound of a
lot of guitars and a lot of the
sort of string instruments they're
Robyn's very fond of the piano and we
wound up kind of having that as part of
the caller as well and he was you know
most people don't know but Robyn is a
very accomplished musician and a
vocation and it was a very it was a
great experience to be able to talk at a
very high level but at the same time
Robyn is so experienced and has worked
with so many incredible composers and
that he was very respectful of their
relationship and was able to give me
notes that were more you know conceptual
in general without doing it to go you
know change that chord there that I
don't like it or anything like that it
was much more you know directing what I
would say is direct direct me like you
would direct an actor in what did CP and
and teach you what did you learn from
working on this film and and with
shepherding this story I mean when you
know anytime you start a story like this
and you start to as a writer to you're
trying to figure out what is about what
what you zoom out you say what is what
am i is trying to say here what does it
mean to me and it started out for me as
labels how we label each other and my
first thought was okay I'm gonna show
them very stereotypically in the first
act as if that's how they saw each other
and then as the movie progressed they
would become real people to us and each
other but that I realized pretty soon
that wasn't gonna work so but it was
about labels it was about how I and I do
it every day I turn on the TV or I look
at Twitter and somebody makes me angry
and I don't know them and I you know and
that's what we do and they labeled each
other but it eventually became for me
about they weren't just an
african-american activist and a racist
they were both powerful leaders in their
community with a lot of people that
would follow them to the ends of the
earth and so she made up her mind to
know that if she changed him that would
have an effect right because and it's a
and his courage was
once he got to that point instead of
saying not admitting that he now
regretted and so he the courage of his
leadership was you know what yeah my
whole life has been wrong and I've met
some people that were in his youth clan
core and and they changed because of him
so that for me it was about leadership
you know thank you for sharing thanks
for having us everything thank you